today I'm heading my best friends here
I'm outgoing in a more spiritual way and
she's really outgoing like I feel like
she's like the next Broadway star she
would look ravishing in a long longer
bob um kind of similar to Kate Bosworth
I'm thinking oh yeah hurts I think the
best haircut style would be like the
long layers like Sofia Vergara it makes
me really nervous that I can't see you
cutting my hair like there's no mirror
I'm a little nervous but at the same
time I have a lot of trust in her so I
think I think this will be good I start
some touching your boobie maybe because
I have like sick like wavy hair it won't
really won't show too much it's a big
fish it's bad no it's a bit it just
sounds like a ton of hair coming off of
my head right now you have like
particularly loud hair are you cutting
upward no I just like I don't think it
does anything it's not nearly as bad as
you think it is why didn't it goes that
bad
well if you ever doubt that I trust you
Liz guess we have this video to look
back on I'm just gonna do like a trim
this right here because just keep this
nice and even and keep saying even he's
like it is not currently it's no it is
it is even for the most part turn to me
real quick and look at your track
bringing one hair over to the other I
know why you're doing this what are we
talking I don't think it was about at
all
I think it's but a good amount of hair
not looking bad does not mean that it
looks good
go ahead okay right I'm doing okay kinda
this is chopped ha ha ha okay okay she
should not cut anybody over here girl
moocher I am surprised but I am happy
with it I'm really happy with it
she can cut too short and there there is
some layering very minor but there's
some layering going on here I see it
it's good oh I still love you
ah I'm definitely going to the salon
that doesn't be stressing out over there
but at a good time yeah and you look
great I love it I love the - thank you
you know